21 km de pistes cyclables en plus de
grandes artères en partie ou
complètement piétonne tous les week-ends
la transformation urbaine de barcelone
qui se voulait temporaire sera
finalement définitive une véritable
bouffée d'oxygène pour les habitants de
la ville qui possède l'une des densités
les plus fortes en europe
des changements qui interviennent alors
que le corona virus circule toujours
dans la cité catalane
c'est une bonne chose
le seul côté positif de l'épidémie c'est
que nous avons réduit la pollution alors
c'est une manière de garder cet acquis
et puis nous avons aussi plus d espace
pour marcher et pour maintenir les
distances de sécurité
donc c'est génial je pourrais prendre le
vélo il ya moins de risque de
contamination donc ça me semble très
bien c'est vrai que pour les gens qui
ont des voitures ce sera plus compliqué
mais c'est un changement complètement
logique et c'est une bonne chose
comme d'autres grandes villes dans le
monde barcelone tente de réduire la
pollution atmosphérique et sonore
plusieurs grandes artères existe
toujours à l'image de la rue arago où
circulent chaque jour plus de 85 mille
véhicules sur cinq voix pour les
associations de quartier la
transformation urbaine ne va pas encore
assez loin il faut diminuer la
circulation des voitures dans la ville
ait une initiative qui a été reporté et
continue d'être reporté
c'est la zone de base émission qui
couvrirait la zone à l'intérieur des
périphériques de la ville où la
circulation serait réduite de manière
significative
face à ces défis la maire de barcelone a
annoncé un investissement de plus de 2
millions d'euros pour pérenniser
ces changements urbain